is across nevada getting help rebuilding  after the pandemic force closures in  widespread layoffs  employ nevada business hub open today at  the sahara west library  their goal is to have workforce  development professionals help local  businesses with  recruiting hiring and training you have  multiple agencies multiple funding  streams coming together to make it  easier for the employers they don't have  to go to multiple places  here you find all those resources under  one roof  this is the second hub brought to las  vegas the first one is inside the vegas  chamber  the employee nevada business hub is open  all businesses at no cost  now if you're looking for a job several  companies are hiring there's where you  can find a  a list with links to apply we put it  together on our website 8newsnow.com  simply click the job board tab